yeah I noticed that millennials  don't seem to care about the character  of the person they don't care about  what's inside they just seem to be  shallow and care about what's on the  outside how much money you have we live  who your friends are is that true yes  and why is that how did it become that  way it wasn't always that way well it  was because before it was birth control  that's what I think started everything  was because that's what if you look at  the divorce rate and the rate of women  on birth control they're like the same  and so what I think it was is basically  the hose  what do birth control give you house  right and so before like women had to  prioritize a guy that had good character  and would stick around right but then  when you give them birth control it  gives them the opportunity to sleep with  like for for shallow things right